Speaker 1: Let's go next to let's go to Ittai
from Copenhagen, Denmark.
Speaker 4: Hi, David, it's good to be on.
Speaker 1: It's a pleasure to have you.
Speaker 4: Yeah. I wanted to ask you, what
are the odds that given the Democratic presidential
candidate in twenty twenty four wins, the
Electoral College and the Republican candidate
refuses to concede that the Republican controlled
Congress will overturn the election and make,
said Republican candidate the next president
of the US.
Speaker 1: So that's a that's a really good
question. So let me let me restate the scenario
so people understand it. Some Democratic candidate
wins the 2024 presidential election. Maybe
it's Biden. Maybe it's someone else. They
win, they get more electoral votes. They are
supposed to be the next president. However,
Republicans, let's imagine control both the
House and the Senate. Could they successfully
prevent the winner from becoming the president
of the United States? My instinct, Itai, is
to say No, it wouldn't happen. They don't
really have the power. They tried to take
that power. Some of them did in 2020. They
don't really have the power, so there's no
way in hell that they prevent the democratic
winner from becoming the president. That's
my instinct. But then I think about, well,
hold on a second. Even in 2020, they weren't
close, but they were close to making it tough.
And so if they were in full control? What
would happen and then I start to get a little
bit scared.
Speaker 4: Let's hope the former case is true.
I also wanted to ask you, what topic would
you like to be taught in public school that
would make the American public more politically
aware and engaged
Speaker 1: a critical thinking and media literacy?
Speaker 4: Oh, that's good, I I would have
picked a course on political ideologies, so
people at least know what the different terms
actually mean.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I see that as only really
being useful if everybody already is educated
in critical thinking and media literacy. I
see those as previous prior steps to jumping
into political ideology, but I don't disagree
with you.
Speaker 4: I see. I also wanted to suggest
that you should cover less the hate mail that
you get beer chats and from voicemails. It's
because we already know that you are getting
it. OK. I mean, I mean, it's it's a given.
I would suggest if unless it's constructive
criticism to just ignore it because it's yeah,
it's not worth your time.
Speaker 1: So listen, I understand that we
do on Fridays. In the last segment, we do
10 minutes of emails and usually there's like
two that are negative. So it's like ten minutes
on one show a week and it's only one or two
of those minutes. So I understand the opinion.
It's a really small part of what we do.
Speaker 4: Oh, I see. Yeah, that was me. How
is. Yeah. Here in Denmark, just so your audience
knows the COVID pandemic is soon over. There
are still some cases, but we don't wear masks
or anything.
Speaker 1: OK. Yeah, there's really no masks
in the in the U.S. either. Hey, real quick,
can you very slowly pronounce Copenhagen the
way you do in Denmark? Because I struggle
to understand how you guys pronounce it? Can
you say it once slowly for me in Danish or
English? In Danish?
Speaker 4: Paraben Howard, it's because the
Earth is a sound that doesn't exist in English.
Speaker 1: OK, and say it one more time slowly
for me.
Speaker 4: Kerr, burn down.
Speaker 1: Wow, so so that the G really disappears.
Speaker 4: Yeah, it does, it does. It's more
of a v sound. Got it, got it.
Speaker 1: All right. Very good. Thank you.
I appreciate the call. Thank you, David, and
have a
nice day. You, too. There's it's high from.
Copenhagen is the way I say it.